to win this now you can just move the
night you can give a check you can bring
the knight back
uh
to where it came from
any any any square for nice works yeah
yeah
and white's king only has one safe
square now you have to go up the board
that is not going gonna be safe wow what
a crazy moment you guys 16 year old
about to beat magnus carlsen
yeah and uh he's just trying to cling on
magnus has literally got his fingernails
now uh just clinging onto that cliff
edge yeah but oh wow what a move black
cuts the coordination between white's
queen and the second rank and is magnus
about to resign is he going to throw in
the towel white knight now
hit by the black queen and if it moves
there's a deadly check in the corner
it's just game over yeah game over wow
has he ever won before pregnant against
magnus carlsen in any official game i
don't think so i don't think i don't
think so it's a historical moment and
it's here magnus carlsen the world
champion loses to 16 year old pregnant
on that look at prague
you can almost not believe it